why
so while we've talked about running the
accuser and Captain Marvel and the
Inhumans we have never had a proper
discussion about the race of the Kree
and right now seems to be an ample time
to do this simply because of the fact
that an agents of shield Marvel has come
out and said that the alien that had
existed in the episode Tahiti was in
fact Acree and so it seems as though
Marvel is bringing the Kree into the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and so what
we're going to do with this video is
we're going to talk about things in the
quanta logical order of the Kree and
what that means is that because of the
way that Marvel introduces elements
because of different retcons and things
like that to take place we're going to
find that our discussions in relation to
the actual comic books are going to be
out of chronological order and so we'll
jump from Captain Marvel volume 1 issue
number 38 and then we'll jump to x-men
annual and then we'll jump to about
about 20 years later to Hickman's run of
the Fantastic Four and so on and so
forth and so we're going to do this in a
way where hopefully it makes sense to
you guys
now what we had seen in something we had
previously discussed especially in our
video about Ron and the accuser was the
origins of the Kree race and what we had
found was that in the history of the
Kree some were along the line they had
encountered these scrolls and the
scrolls had been traveling across the
cosmos in an effort to bring in various
races for the purpose of expanding their
empire of Commerce and when they came
across the Large Magellanic Cloud the
part of the universe which holds the
Kree on their home planet of Halle they
can encounter two races the first of
which was of course the very primitive
Kree but the other race was the Cotati
and what we had seen with both of these
races is that the scrolls had taken them
both to the moon and they had placed
them there with the years worth of
supplies and they had basically told
them to do what it is they felt was
appropriate to do something to build
something and so at the end of the year
the scrolls had come back and when they
did they found the Kree had built this
very elaborate I guess citadel of sorts
and this and the
Tati had built this very lush garden now
because the scrolls at this particular
point in time we're a very piece going
race they had decided to ally themselves
with the Cotati and in response to this
the Cree had more or less been very
upset and so what they did is they
killed the the scroll delegates they
reverse-engineer the scroll technology
and began to implement a new era of
their society now between this point and
time and uncanny x-men annual number 11
the Cree had at some point or another
created the supreme intelligence and the
supreme intelligence is basically an
amalgamation of all the best minds that
have ever existed and the Kree Empire up
to that particular point in time what
this means is that the science division
had more or less taken the minds taking
the physical brains of a previous Kree
and they had connected them into one
massive network and what this allows the
supreme intelligence to do is to analyze
things in a way that anyone normal Kree
simply couldn't do it endowed the
supreme intelligence with various forms
of telepathy and telekinesis and so on
but more so than that the supreme
intelligence is really more of a
spiritual force that's really more of a
spiritual leader for the Kree society
now with uncanny x-men annual issue
number eleven the story itself had
revolved around something called the
crystal of ultimate vision and what this
crystal did is it more or less put the
person that was trying to capture it
through a test it would endow its user
the person that was wielding it with
virtually godlike power but the downside
here is that if the person chooses to
use the crystal then the person will be
killed it will become a guardian for the
the crystal of ultimate vision and that
an individual's race will be frozen in
time with regards to its evolution now
it's not until the very end of the story
that we learned this is actually what
happened with the Kree that at some
point along the line a member of the
Kree had tried to capture the crystal of
ultimate vision and when they did the
entire evolution of the Kree race had
been frozen and it wasn't able to move
forward anymore and it lasted this way
for some unspecified amount of time
again we don't know exactly when this
happened we simply know that it was just
something that took place but from here
we jump again to the few
sure with a Hickman's run of the
Fantastic Four with issue number six and
the story of the two kings and what
Hickman tells us in this story is that
again
somewhere along the line without giving
us an exact date now the supreme
intelligence had initiated something
called the meta Genesis project and what
this was was the Kree Empire going about
the process of seating different planets
with I guess the genes of the Kree
within the existing people within the
existing society and to make this a very
simple example we're going to go with
the Inhumans and what the Kree had done
is they had travel to the planet Earth
and they had abducted several of the
indigenous species Homo sapiens at the
time and they had implanted in them were
planted and then the seeds of Cree but
what happened here is that once these I
guess these people these groups were
exposed to something called the Terrigen
mists they would in turn take on a
multitude of different forms now we
won't find out later on until why this
was done but what the supreme
intelligence realizes is that somewhere
off in the distant future there's going
to be a situation whereby one member of
this race or possibly an entire race is
going to rise up against the Kree Empire
it was more or less a prophecy that had
been foretold and so what the supreme
intelligence did was order the the
accuser Corps to eliminate the
scientists who had been the I guess the
push behind the entire meta Genesis
project as well as lemonade all the meta
Genesis test subjects now of course we
know they weren't successful when it got
around to the to the Inhumans of course
the Inhumans were able to survive this
great purge and as a result they were
able to continue their evolution and and
move towards their current state but
from here we jump to Avengers vol 1
issue number 347 and what is is it's
part of an event called the goal called
Operation galactic storm and with
operation galactic storm this was a
situation whereby the Kree and the Shiar
had engaged in war with one another now
over the course of the conflict over the
course of the series we have course see
various things taking place and we see
that this big crossover playing itself
out but with issue number 347 what we
see is that the Shiar empire detonates
something called the Nega bomb and what
we have seen
here was that this story had been played
out and more or less been instigated by
the supreme intelligence the supreme
intelligence had basically instigated a
conflict with the Shiar knowing that
eventually the Shiar was going to use
the negev um and when they did it was
going to wipe out 98 percent of the Cree
population but what this would do is
force the Cree population to evolve it
would basically jumpstart the
evolutionary stagnation that you're
previously and and allow the race to
begin moving toward its - I guess
tortoise evolutionary end and so from
here we jump to Avengers vol 3 issue
number 35 with maximum security
then what maximum security tells us is
it introduces us to the I guess the next
stage of the of the Kree evolution when
we're introduced to a race called the
rule and this is the very interesting
thing when it comes to the cream with
the Kree society itself you have the
blue-skinned decree you have those Kree
who look almost exactly like humans with
the exception of the fact that they may
be a little bit larger in their physical
size their bodies are more dense and so
they're physically stronger they're
immune to the kind of diseases that
humans are not immune to but among the
Kree Empire you also have pink skin
decree and the pink skin create are the
Kree who have chosen to procreate with
races outside of the Kree and so these
pink skin crea are looked down upon they
are a lesser class than their blue
scanty counterparts but because the
detonation of the Nega bomb and because
of the fact that 98% of the Kree were
killed while some of the Kree remained
they maintain their physical form in
terms of their blue skin that this new
race of the Kree were vastly different
but what the supreme intelligence tells
us is that this new race of create it's
evolutionary I guess progress in the
sense that they can physically adapt
themselves to any situation if they need
to fly they can develop wings if they
need to breathe underwater they can
develop the the physiology to do so and
so this is why the supreme intelligence
looks at the rule and says that the rule
are more or less better than the normal
blue skin Creek however for the most
part the blue skin crease still
maintained the hierarchical control of
the Kree Empire now from here we jump to
Inhumans volume 3 and what we had seen
with this four issue
run was that the Shiar Empire is still
under control or is still controlling
the Kree Empire as a result of the
events of Operation galactic storm and
so what run in the accuser is looking to
do here as he is looking to find a way
to force the Inhumans to operate under
the control of the Kree and this is when
we learn the basis behind the formation
of the Inhumans what ron in the accuser
tells us here is that when the meta
Genesis project was conceived it was
designed in such a way so that the the
Kree once they took on their final form
once they were exposed to the Terrigen
mists or the equivalent of the Terrigen
mists on whatever other planet had
happened to be on that they would go
through a physical change they would
literally change their physical form and
when they did they would take on the
form of another race and what this would
allow the Kree to do is to use this
individual to infiltrate that race and
to perhaps overthrow that the the ruling
Empire of that planet or of that total
Society maybe assassinate someone but it
would allow the Kree to gain an upper
edge it was basically a giant espionage
project and so what we have seen was
that when when Ronon the accuser had
realized that the Inhumans had survived
the Great Purge he was looking to take
the Inhumans and force them into
servitude and then force them to
infiltrate the Shiar Empire and attempt
to overthrow the Shiar Empire but what
we saw was that blackbolt had refused
this blackbolt had refused to play the
schemes to play out the role that ron
and the accuser was trying to impose on
him and so what he did is each
Challenger on the accuser to a deal and
a to a to a duel and he had told running
the accuser that if Ronon wins then the
Inhumans will take on the role that run
in the accuser is trying to force on
them they will operate as agents of the
Kree Empire
but if blackbolt wins blackbolt will
take over the role as king as a ruler of
the Kree and Ronon the accuser will step
down of course we see that blackbolt is
successful in defeating one in the
accuser and as a result blackbolt
becomes king but what blackbolt does is
he travels back to the planet earth to
his to Attilan and he leaves running the
accuser to to function as king in his
stead and so from here we jump to the
annihilation
storyline and with the annihilation
storyline what we see is actually a
limited series I believe a four or five
part limited series for running the
accuser then what we learn is that
somewhere along the line again a group
called the Fierro house had taken over
control of the Kree Empire and when they
did they had banished one on the accuser
under the guise that he was a traitor
which of course false testimony was
given at the hands of Tana Nile and so
during the entire annihilation event
whereby Annihilus is tending to take
over and eliminate all life in the
mainstream Marvel Universe run in the
accuser is trying to find out what
happened with regards to his to the to
the accusations with regards to the
success of the Fierro house taking over
the Kree Empire eventually running the
accuser is able to find out what
happened he's able to I kill the head of
the Fierro house who had accused him of
treason but in the process the supreme
intelligence is rendered lobotomized and
as a result the supreme intelligence is
no longer able to function as the
spiritual leader of the Kree Empire and
so Ron in the accuser destroys the tank
that the supreme intelligence was housed
in there by killing the supreme
intelligence entirely now the supreme
intelligence will come back during the
annihilation conquest storyline and
especially after the annihilation
conquest storyline but for the most part
the supreme intelligence doesn't
maintain the same role that he
previously did in the sense that there's
a little bit of distrust here there's a
little bit of acknowledgment on behalf
of the Kree that the supreme
intelligence despite his vast
intelligences capabilities can still be
rendered almost non-existent can still
be killed off or the very least removed
from the equation but for the sake of
this discussion we're going to go ahead
and bring this video to an end we're not
going to get too in-depth with regards
to a lot of those feature stories
because those are things that we'll get
into with later videos but with that
being said I hope this explanation made
sense to you guys I hope it was was
explained in a way that you guys are
able to have two pieces together to it
the very least come to an understanding
of what the Krieger about and of course
if you have any questions I'll answer
them in the comments
without being said I will catch you guys
later peace